well well
well
not the werewolf indeed
man i saw this circulating last night
all over social media i'm sure you've
already heard of it by this point andrew
garfield was on the tonight show and he
was talking about that leaked photo but
now there's like even a leaked video of
it jimmy fallon addressed it on the
tonight show as a leaked photo and i
loved how
jimmy fallon at one point was asked to
show it andrew garfield asked him jimmy
fallon's like no it's been taken off the
internet we know it's all over the
internet there are youtube channels that
have it just as the video alone but he
can't jimmy fallon can't because it's a
nationally broadcast television show and
that is a leaked video so uh they get in
a lot of trouble for showing it but when
andrew garfield's being pressed on it
he's denying it the way how he did a few
months ago when he i'm not the werewolf
i'm not the werewolf when he was doing
that there's just such a different tone
and cadence to the way now he approaches
it offset of it he kept acting like he
didn't know what the photo was i don't
know what photo you're talking about and
then by the end of the interview he was
like i i do i actually did see that
photo and it's photoshopped and he say
he wants to manage expectations going in
which i totally respect and i admire
it's like we all know
we we know
i said last night on social media he
knows the cat's way out of the bag but
what i love so much about what he's
doing this time around is he's not just
coming out and saying yeah yeah it's
late everyone knows i'm in it now he's
sticking to his guns he's he's sticking
to what he has to do some might say
and this is probably the case that he
can't because of the contract that he
signed where he can't disclose that he
is in it the other side of me is going
like you know alfred molina let it out
of the bag by this point i mean would he
get in trouble for confirming it
probably yeah at the same time though
what's fun is that just that twinkle in
his eye and just the way he's now doing
the denial he's turned it into a comedy
bit it's like you can tell
that he's fully aware that people know
he's lying
that's what's making this so fun there's
such a self-awareness now in the way how
he's denying it he's turned it into just
a classic comedy bit so i just really
hope that i mean and the rumor is that
you might see them in the second trailer
toby mcguire and andrew garfield but i
really hope that from here on out he
just continues to do this level of
performance when it comes to denying
that he's inspiring because before when
he was they do that i'm not the werewolf
interview he it seemed like he was like
stressed about having to ask it or
something that's just the way i at least
i interpreted it was that he was trying
to just move past it drop it and there
was his level of like stress and
pressure now it seems like he's actually
having some fun with it and one part of
the interview that i actually really
liked a lot
was how he talked about tom holland how
he said like tom holland is just the
perfect peter parker and spider-man
andrew garfield is someone who's been
pretty candid about like how much
spider-man meant to him
and how excited he was to be cast in the
role and how distraught and heartbroken
he was over what happened with
the amazing spider-man series how that
all went down i'm sure at some point he
he's actually said like how great of an
actor tom holland is and everything i
haven't caught it is the first time i've
caught him saying something like that
but for him to say he's like the perfect
peter parker spider-man it's just so
heartwarming and endearing to hear him
say that i'm glad to be a fan of tom
holland as this character who i once
played and on top of that too it's it's
also
that much more special because of the
fact that edgar garfield is going to be
in spiderman no way home yeah they're
just my quick thoughts on it i know it's
circulating around everywhere but uh
guys what did you think about the
interview with edgy garfield did you
enjoy it
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that bell hit that like button and
we'll catch you guys soon
[Music]
you